so i i don't know like how much you you
like follow my content
but a lot of my um my streams and my
videos
uh i i like to to experiment with these
these kind of new
yeah obscure weird openings that aren't
necessarily sound but have a lot of
interest
um and richness to them so it's one
thing that keeps me like passionate
about chess
or if i had to play the same repertoire
over and over i'd probably just get
bored eventually
but yeah yeah yeah luckily chess always
has something extra to offer to us so
it's
it's good stuff yeah have you heard of
the um
oh there's so many have you heard of the
nagminson gambit
oh my it's quite hilarious you mentioned
it because the other day a student of
mine sent me a link
about your video and also sent me an
analysis in the study
uh and saying that that's uh eric
rosen's
channel this is all the new rage and
then what's this all about and tell me
what to do
and i'm like oh okay have a look at this
and then i did have a look at this
i have seen it before and the refutation
is quite mind-bending
yeah yeah um there's actually another
chess youtuber uh
jonathan truntz who does like a lot of
content just focused on these weird
gambits
so i learned it from him um but it's
it's not easy to refute
yeah yeah i agree with that if you face
it for the first
time uh having said that when it this
came up on the board with my student i
and i did look at the the main variation
which
is absolute insanity because here
apparently the only refutation is king
up
yeah which is i mean you're not gonna
require
serious size of cojones to play like
this
i wouldn't have the guts but what i said
to my student is what i do not
understand is that why is black not
clearly better after two natural moves
like this
black is yeah this is unfortunate part
there there's a few ways for black to
climb it
but there's still some traps here oh
undoubtedly
undoubtedly but this is how i would play
if i was black
because it feels to me that i keep some
advantage but i take away a lot of the
bite
that's true yeah i i was looking into
this other day
i have to compromise king
and i'm going with stockfish here for
the record so don't take the time that
that's smart
there is one like natural human line
which i was looking at involving bishop
d7
white can simply take and if bishop
takes white's already winning
with rookie one and then bishop a3 yes
so there's still some some venom it's a
slippery slope
it's for sure yeah um i didn't actually
know the existence of this until it was
brought to my attention
yeah knight d6 was also a move but no no
one will ever play this
yeah again freaks me out
now on this note i will show you
something that i was really fascinated
by
as a junior player but never got around
playing speaking of a gambit again
so in my junior years i saw a lot of
people playing this
which is a really really fascinating
variation this is like the frank
is this like the frankenstein dracula
i've made i don't know these
like names okay i don't really know them
either to be totally honest with you i
really frown upon these names because i
just go like people just came up with
some random rubbish
i tend to be a little bit old school for
my own good and i really like to respect
chess players and chess innovators and
name openings after them
rather than dracula who had yeah never
had anything to do with chess and or an
opening but that was not a go at you
it's just a general thing that
people come up with these days with very
fancy names so yeah this variation
back in the day uh enjoyed a great deal
of popularity and again if you look at
stockfish's evaluation
it smashes it but to be white in this
position
it's not easy at all like this bishop b7
is coming at you knight d4 is coming at
you
we have no center to speak off and not
easy target to grab onto and
attack yeah and this is one reason why
you can't always trust the engine
to give you a reflection of like
practically how how easy a position is
to play
well yes unless you have got
photographic memory and you memorize all
these lines which i doubt one can do
yes the engine is is somewhat to be
neglected in these cases
well each i'm not saying by the way that
this line is sound for black but it
looks like a lot of fun
yeah and then sometimes that's like you
can save these sort of openings for
blitz or bullets or just non-rated games
exactly
exactly so there is again a gambit for
you that
could uh occur on the occasion and uh
yeah now i do have to yeah go ahead
no no you go i i wanted okay so first of
all chat is screaming
if you've if you've seen the jerome and
what you think about it
i'm sorry i i again am i oh again yeah
so
have you at least heard the the name
jerome gambit
no ah that's maybe
why i set a time out of my death but
maybe when i see it i would go like ah
yeah okay
that's it i don't think that will be
your reaction but um
jerome gambit is bishop f7 here
and then 95 or is it 95 not i have seen
it i have some okay
95 95 and then queen h5 check
yep and if you make any video
about it on youtube yeah like every
everyone's searching for it and there's
very little
content about it it's in high demand
and it's it's kind of turned into this
internet meme
um because there's this uh there's a
blog website that has
years upon years of like analysis and
games
uh stemming from from this opening
and it's completely refuted but uh
there's some people who are like very
passionate about it
see this is eric where you and i differ
greatly in terms of how we respond
to some of the um the very traditional
nutritional but fashionable things that
are happening around in the world in
chess circles because
um like i said occasionally i tend to be
too serious for my own good
and if someone presented this to me in
any other circumstances
i would just would have if i had said
trash that would have been a very polite
way to deal with this
and i would have recommended them not to
waste both mine and their time
let's move on to actually what matters
but
um it is more than likely a serious
shortcoming of mine
that i look down on things that are
indeed
probably trash but a lot of fun
i mean this this is how we're raised is
um as like serious chess players
is you want to be objective and you
don't want to
spend well the problem is that almost
every time
i see anything that is a chessboard and
a question
i tend to have my chess coach hat on
which i really shouldn't
especially if i really do want to grow
my youtube channel
i really need to engage with questions
and topics like this more frequently
sure yeah totally right that this is
what the hype is all about so
the objective evaluation of this
position is essentially relevant
mm-hmm and the thing about this
shouldn't stop you from giving like your
your true opinion but i think there
there would be a lot of potential for
you
to make a video just titled like why the
jerome is complete
trash i will start a myth mythbusters
series
on my channel where i'm going to just
put out the refutations of all these
amazing gambits having said that i will
have to use you as my ultimate source
because
you seem to never run out of these
absolutely
cuckoo variations i mean trust is just
an infinite game like there's always
always new stuff popping up and kudos to
you for this by the way because uh
like that uh trick that you showed to
that uh
um
that stream with the chess-based india i
was just again like
h5 like who does that
yeah i can't really take credit for i
can never take credit for like inventing
uh an opening or a gambit because it's
all discovered and
i think it's it's just um it's been a
result
of just being passionate about obscure
openings
and perhaps digging like digging into
like
maybe lower level games to find hidden
gems
yeah right okay so not everyone has that
that kind of
passion or intrigue um yeah no i i think
it's a superb angle on it though because
it's so
entertaining and by you being willing to
engage
with things that on your level are
unsound it also sends a message that you
know we are all in one family and it
doesn't matter whether you are
2400 2700 or whatever the heck
we are just here for the chess and the
love of the game so who cares if it's
unsound
for sure yeah and um i mean i i don't
think too many like top level players
share
this perspective but like i think
carlson is a great example of this like
sometimes in racing
it's just like wildly dubious or troll
openings
just to show that you can try and get
away with it yeah sure
there was one yeah there was one game he
played against ding and some like st
louis rapid and blitz
where he played this uh this costume
gambit
like super he got like crushed like
absolutely crushed yeah yeah but it's
still like fun to see like
strong players kind of tinker with these
openings and see if they
they can work right okay
um i posted a
game i don't know if it was my on my
older youtube channel
so not to cut you off but i i think that
whatever like five minutes discussion
like that was great
great perspective from uh i think
um just just offering like kind of
contrasting insights
into the nature of these like these
weird gametes i might just post that
that clip to my channel and then link
whatever you post to your channel so if
this goes on youtube
people on youtube look in the video
description check out andres
on his channel there will be links check
out his chestable course
if you're watching live on twitch the
links are already in the chat his
youtube channel and his adjustable
course